mobilisé des moyens exceptionnels c'est
la volonté du gouvernement espagnol
un conseil des ministres extraordinaire
est prévu ce samedi pour faire face à la
propagation du coronavirus dans le pays
ces décisions viseront à mobiliser
toutes les ressources de l'étape tout
entier pour mieux protéger la santé de
tous les citoyens les ressources
économiques pour la santé tant publics
que privés ville tant civils que
militaires pour la protection de tous
les citoyens en particulier ceux qui
sont les plus vulnérables face au virus
en raison de leur âge ou de leur
pathologie antérieure ce vendredi
commerce barzé écoles ont déjà fermé des
conséquences économiques qui inquiète
les espagnols
néanmoins compréhensif il ya des pertes
commerciales parce que nous avons de
nombreuses dépenses il ya des employés
et puis cela cause des dommages nous
allons choisir de fermer pendant quinze
jours compte tenu du fait que nous ne
pouvons pas continuer afin de faire de
la prévention et de traiter de manière
responsable cette tragédie et cette
épidémie le plus rapidement possible le
conseil municipal a appelé ce matin
parce que nous devons démonter toutes
les terrasses de madrid jusqu'à nouvel
ordre et à titre préventif et en bon
chef de gouvernement aideront sanchez
n'a pas manqué de rappeler l'essentiel
la victoire dépend de chaque individu
l'héroïsme
c'est aussi se laver les mains et rester
chez soi
[Musique]